fin de dos días de cumbre de la otan
envina capital de lituania en que el
presidente
ucranianonski no ha conseguido una
invitación formal y una fecha concreta
de cuándo va a poder entrar Ucrania
dentro de la ota los aliados se han
asegurado que esto se va a producir una
vez la guerra haya acabado pero aún así
bueno de Mireles que sí que ha
conseguido las garantías de seguridad
por parte de los países del g7 que
llevaba semanas pidiendo los países del
g7 han ofrecido un plan a largo plazo en
que ofrecen todo tipo de asistencia
militar financiera también en
ciberdefensa también en inteligencia en
entrenamiento de las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas para que estén lo máximo
preparadas para una vez puedan entrar
dentro de la alianza Y esto es lo clave
porque estas garantías se van a extender
hasta que Ucrania pueda formar parte
dentro de la otan los aliados han
asegurado que ahora mismo tras esta
Cumbre Ucrania está más cerca que nunca
de la alianza de hecho se le han
ofrecido
una serie de contrapartidas y de
garantías que no se habían ofrecido
nunca hasta ahora ningún país que no
formara parte de la Organización de esta
Cumbre también se ha celebrado el primer
consejo formal entre Ucrania y la otan
en que se va a reforzar la cooperación
entre ambos bloques una cooperación
entre iguales a la espera de que en el
futuro se puedan convertir en una
cooperación entre países aliados la
alianza considera que ahora mismo A
pesar de que no se ha podido producir
esta invitación formal Ucrania en el
futuro sí que formará parte de la
alianza a pesar de que Vladimir zelenski
esperaba algo más paralelamente a esta
Cumbre también se ha conseguido que
Suecia en un futuro próximo pueda
convertirse en el nuevo miembro de la
alianza porque Turquía ha avanzado que
desbloqueará su adhesión El parlamento
Turco ahora tendrá que formalizar la
ratificación de la entrada de Suecia
aunque no hay una fecha concreta erdogan
asegurado que se pueda producir lo antes
posible